these are our kids these are our
neighbors not somebody else's kids
they're all our kids lgbtq Americans
especially children you're loved you're
heard and this Administration has your
back uh Joe Biden has the backs of
children who are confused about their
either gender or sexuality or something
like that but to that point Elon Musk
responded to the White House's tweet
about this uh oh there are kids he wrote
you are the government they are not your
kids I mean there are a lot of people
that do think it takes a village they're
everybody's kids nobody really should
have the ultimate Authority on this
child it's the that's not the
government's job to make any decisions
like that about your children you are
the parent I am the parent stay out of
my like I stay out the decisions for my
child